how's it going everyone it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel cinematic universe now
this past
year has been pretty rough for us marvel
fans marvel's phase 4 schedule got
completely thrown off course thanks to
the coronavirus
along with the rest of the world marvel
studios was severely affected by the
pandemic
and they've pretty much had to
reschedule most of their entire phase 4
slate and not only were movies pushed
back but the order that phase 4 was
originally supposed to be in
is no longer the same but 2021 is
stacked with marvel films both in the
mcu and
out of the mcu so in this video i'm
going to go over marvel's new phase 4
slate all of the new release dates and
everything that you need to know about
the production of all of the current
marvel projects going on right now
if you are new and you love the mcu be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a tony stark funko pop provided
by heroeshideout.com you can check out
their website for some awesome marvel
funko's and
gear so originally as most people know
black widow was supposed to be the first
film and project of
marvel's phase four coming out in may of
2020
well may 1st has come and gone and we
did not get black widow
but instead the first marvel project
that we're going to be getting to kick
off phase 4
is going to be the wanda vision series
coming to disney plus
marvel and disney recently announced the
official release date for the one
division series and it's going to be
january 15th
of 2021 so we don't have to wait that
much longer for it and especially if you
consider the fact that the original
release date for the one division series
was supposed to be in
spring of 2021 so we're actually getting
it sooner than we were supposed to
now what should be next in line is the
falcon in the winter soldier series
however right now currently we do not
have a release date for it marvel has
been pretty secretive about the falcon
in the winter soldier lately
now the production was put on pause due
to the pandemic but production did
resume and now we're in post-production
for the series
so they're done filming and now in
post-production and editing originally
we were supposed to get this
in fall of 2020 and since we don't have
a release date right now we can only
assume that it's going to be relatively
close to black widow
this is for continuity purposes it's
said that the falcon and the winter
soldier do connect to what happens in
black widow and
marvel's executive vice president has
already commented stating that they are
keeping the continuity
with all of their shows and movies in
the mcu that are coming out despite the
changes in the schedule
which means we can expect the falcon in
the winter soldier between january 15th
and may 7th of 2021 and of course as
soon as we get an official release date
i'll be sure to update everybody on that
and speaking of black widow its current
release date is may 7th of 2021 as i
just mentioned but its original release
date was supposed to be may 1st
now black widow's production has been
done for a pretty long time now it's
just a waiting game at this point so
let's hope there are no more delays and
we actually get the movie
in theaters on may 7th coming up next if
nothing changes is the loki series now
right now it is currently filming in
atlanta and the lot
right next to where they're filming
spider-man 3. so hopefully we'll get
some leaked photos and videos pretty
soon we've already gotten a bunch in the
past but hopefully
some new ones are coming soon now the
original release date is spring
of 2021 which is still the current
listed release date so let's hope
everything stays on track and we'll
still get it in spring of 2021.
now this next one is kind of a bonus one
it's not in the mcu technically but
venom let there be carnage this is
supposed to come out on june 5th of 2021
it was originally supposed to come out
on october 2nd of 2020 but sony pushed
it back
now everything's done with venom let
there be carnage although we have not
received a
teaser trailer for it yet but hopefully
if nothing changes early on in 2021 we
should be getting a teaser for it
next in the lineup is shang chi and the
legend of the 10
rings now shang chi right now has
finished filming it's in post-production
so everything seems to be on track now
on track at least for its new release
date of july 9th of 2021
its original release date was supposed
to be february 12th of 2021 but fans are
very excited because it's going to be
the first
asian superhero lead and the real
mandarin and the real 10 rings are going
to be making their marvel cinematic
universe debut
and it's also rumored right now that
there are going to be some mutants in
the movie as well
so let's hope that nothing gets pushed
back next in the lineup is marvel's what
if
now not a lot has really been said about
marvel's what if series lately
for a while we had some actors talking
about it and we even had some leaked
photos from it as well
not to mention disney and marvel did
give us a little bit of a teaser as to
what we're going to see by showing us
some very quick clips
but it's been silent for a while however
it still holds the release date of a
summer
2021 release it has not been moved
yet and right now it is currently in
production we know that all of the
original
mcu actors are going to return to do
their own voices and it's been said that
they've already all recorded their parts
so now they're doing the animation and
then moving on to the editing process
which should put it on track for a
summer of 2021 release and then in the
lineup we have the hawkeye series a
series that a lot of people are really
looking forward to
now it's just been revealed that jeremy
renner is starting to get back in shape
for the role of hawkeye and he said that
he hasn't worked out for the role in
a very long time but i'm sure he won't
have a problem getting back in shape
now right now it's planned on being
released in fall of 2021
and the hawkeye producers and writers
have all followed haley steinfeld
on instagram and it's pretty much all
but confirmed that she is indeed going
to be playing kate bishop in the hawkeye
series it's also rumored that they may
be exploring a
comic route where hawkeye was actually
deaf and that he'll go deaf in the
hawkeye series somehow
but we'll have to wait until fall of
2021 to find out
and then in the lineup we have the
eternals now the eternals got pushed
way back by a year the original release
date was supposed to be november 6th of
2020 and now it is coming out on
november 5th
of 2021. now right now it's in
post-production the reshoots actually
just finished and most of the movie
including post-production is pretty much
complete
and of course the big question about the
eternals is when are we going to be
getting this
trailer well right now there's a lot of
talk about us getting it with the
release of
black widow which means we would have to
wait until may to
finally see the trailer but that is
probably when we can expect it to come
out because that's six months before the
film
and then we have the movie that probably
has the most hype around it right now
spider-man 3. now whether it's called
homesick home worlds whatever
fans are super excited for spider-man 3
and the potential for a huge
multiverse film it's been rumored that
there are a ton of people returning from
other franchises to this movie including
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man
as well now it was originally planned
for july 16th of 2021 but unfortunately
it has been pushed back to december 17th
of 2021
and recently over the past couple of
weeks they just started filming it so we
are already getting
leaked photos and leaked videos so the
official title should come out
relatively soon and we should be getting
more leaks including photos and
videos soon as well now that's it for
2021 but we still have a couple of more
projects for
marvel's phase four next in the lineup
is thor
love and thunder a movie that fans are
very very
excited for christian bale is confirmed
to be in the film probably as the main
villain it was just confirmed that chris
pratt will indeed be in thor love and
thunder as well
and natalie portman confirmed that jane
foster will indeed have
breast cancer in the film following a
storyline from the comics now of course
she is going to become a version of thor
herself being able to lift mjolnir so
it's going to be a really
really exciting film now the original
release date for thor love and thunder
was supposed to be on november 5th
of 2021 but unfortunately it got pushed
back to february 15th of 2022
now the final project and movie of
marvel's phase 4
is doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
and based off of everything that we've
heard about this film it is going to be
absolutely insane the multiverse is
going to be burst
open and literally fly into madness
again there are rumors that toby maguire
spider-man is going to be in this film
and other crazy rumors such as
alternate versions of iron man appearing
in the movie being played by
tom cruise there's a lot of hype and a
lot of
mystery surrounding multiverse of
madness but of course we know that wanda
or the scarlet witch at this point in
time is going to be a main character of
this film
but unfortunately we're going to have to
wait until march
25th of 2022 to see it this is a pretty
big pushback considering the fact that
it was supposed to come out on may 7th
of 2021
but now here comes the really big
question are all of these release dates
actually going to hold looking at the
2021 release schedule for marvel right
now if everything keeps its current
release date
that is 10 marvel projects going to
release in 2021.
now if you take venom out because it's
not a part of the mcu that's still
nine marvel typically releases three to
four movies a year
so nine projects is a pretty big upgrade
i'm not complaining i definitely hope it
sticks but i think the odds are we're
most likely going to get some more phase
for reshuffling
but again it's just another thing that
we'll have to wait and see
but right now as it stands this is how
marvel's phase 4
looks let me know if you think that all
of these release dates are going to hold
or if we're going to get another
change and again don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
me